well the stole my idea hey what's going
on we're just turning down the sheets
where's this crime huh who are you
it's unknown yeah what'd you do that for
I was scared
what do we do now run and who might you
be
oh you don't wanna mess with him that's
a stone-cold killer yeah you don't want
to mess with him I mean he's stone-cold
who met boys
babe I seen them rip somebody's guts out
through the ass and the eyes fell out do
the move that you do the cutting eyes
move that's what a gutsman just dropped
okay well I'm bad baby I'll rip your
lips off and kiss my ass with them shits
I've seen him Jewish I do that that's
how I get damn baby I'll rip your tongue
out and lick my balls with shut up check
him out mr. nice guy oh I may have the
wrong number
is his Thurgood around speaking oh hey
hey it's Mary Jane do you remember I
gave you a ride home from prison boom
could you be a little more specific can
I get so many rides home from prison
that was a joke um how that happened I
didn't think you were gonna call me well
I wasn't but then I decided I don't care
what my friends think see that was a
joke
oh so you want to get together okay sure
when how about right now just meet me at
the place we dropped us off it okay um
can you give me half an hour
yeah heaven that was cool great alright
I'll see you there
okay bye bye bye Harry J yeah I got
money that they couldn't have come at a
worse time man I was flat broke all my
money was tied up in our drug-dealing
venture I only had eight books this was
gonna take some careful budgeting and
maneuvering watch the master at work
you look great look wonderful thank you
you know what I was thinking so nice out
wanna go for a walk good good let's so
far so good
three hours and 14 miles later and I had
to spent one penny damn I mean it and
then it happened I'm hungry too
hey you want to eat at the happy palace
we're gonna get you I have a hotdog in
ketchup and sauerkraut please Sarcos
fifty cents extra
hey I've not had a hotdog and so one
come let's get out of here maybe a drink
with that son of a [ __ ] yes
anything we use it no thanks greedy
bastard did you promise me ice cream the
other day I know really good place
uptown
great let's hope it do you mind if we
take a cab this time sure
I'm not funny you see my oh don't mind
if I do
young brother no thank you
yeah I mean I do miss my dad yeah but
what about AIDS AIDS was created in a
laboratory about white Jewish Santa's
there's a conspiracy with the FBI
basically to annihilate the power of the
black nation this is gonna blow your
mind
you know the Holocaust never happened
yeah what about all the stories pictures
she just faked about as real as your
hair but come on look at this [ __ ] I
read a book paved at the page of proof
to say that the Jews made the whole
Holocaust up should never happen hey you
know I think I read that same book you
remember the part about slavery in
America as Paulette is it where the guy
proves that all the african-americans
that came here in the 1600s actually
wanted to come in fact most of them paid
their own way [ __ ] are you talking about
man oh it's true they heard there were
lots of jobs over here picking cotton
which they figured would lead to better
jobs is his muggers and crackheads so
they just all came rushing over here can
you believe it slavery never existed and
this [ __ ] is not even a little bit funny
well it's at least as funny as what you
said about the Holocaust don't you think
how's this for funny beach boy why don't
you get your pail and get out of here
you're [ __ ] fired you got soul we're
in the computer another active Dowling
from the black me
[Music]
what the hell if I wanna hear something
stupid
my ass is skinny black ass hey this is
Undercover Brother come on it good if
you say good morning to me the only
thing you're saying is I'm gonna kill
your black ass first thing in the
morning keep it real
that's all I'm saying hi Chi Minh hi
like hi yellow wanna be white huh I like
the white man was keeping huh hi you
look nice no no we'd only did you yeah
mother can I get a list of the words
that trigger these fits man you really
need to relax you've seen it all through
history they never give black man credit
Jesus Christ black man Babe Ruth's back
man Madonna secret black man pedophile
you're safe I'm with island fortress
cleaning service sir okay thank you
oh look we got the gun man yeah hi Jetta
what I said shut up buddy break things
great what I see you breakdance come on
[Music]
that's right it's good hello play
[Music]
situation complete we'll see you soon
cheap atomic Colerain
see what this button does overload
[Music]
[Applause]
Reggie
[Music]
[Applause]
take this down he's so obnoxious
get a [ __ ] J
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I just scratch on the Internet women be
shopping you can stop right here look at
her you can tell me
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you might win for the plush Lambert I'm
sorry man so funny the way you take a
person's personal defect and flip it
around that's like you're pixelated
rubriz a look at your foot nearby look
at it start laughing that's some funny
[ __ ] man you're on your way you going to
the top doing a clinic boost man
get even work with me doing it to you
Richard yes it would if I would say look
at Reggie's gums and teeth look like his
mother had an affair with mr. ed they
can visualize your mother in the barn
with Miss Edna some oh you living on
Reggie
it's your teeth Reggie I don't know
whether to smile at you to kick a field
goal Reggie you breathless Oh stinky
we'll look forward to you fine
[Applause]
okay you don't live there boy see I
won't wanna fail of them cuz I like
black people but it's time to attack
black that's right yeah the girl pulling
over don't remember maybe it's time for
ready to lose though she with the
scissors and the [ __ ] got a group
discount you all do fat jokes all right
your mother's so fat the [ __ ] needed
thomaswguy to find
whoo-hoo - old Fang after six I roll
over twice and it's still an event -
felony brain candy to get stuck
the toenails painted ocean ridges mama
it's a blood type of rocky road
[Applause]
silence I can't take this [ __ ] no more
comfortable in the boy I try to be but
let it sample rigid the car Joey let's
go too far with the cavity what's now is
that Oh
let's go kick your legs down boy Meera's
you wanna send one out to a very special
lady in the house tonight love in you is
easy cause you're beautiful
[Music]
dundun didn't ready
[Music]
that was pretty ladies and gentlemen
Reggie had left the building
thank you and good night
[Applause]